Tiffany's drinking things every day no
like once a week I was just gonna say
hey guys I'm Bryce Sandra this is
Housewives happy hour and Shannon beador
is here hi hello how are you are you
good well we have our lemons and I just
counted there's nine no and we also have
our vodka i'm in for a little in my
glass if you'll por lo and yours will
mix in ok because i think they might
need to need a sip before we died you
well at least it's not a bottle of wine
trip oh my god they have wine in here
one of mine cast members oh I don't hire
Hal of wine here Anna do that you've
told my friend she was ugly what's he is
ugly [ __ ] you don't call people ugly
well then she does cause I do you think
you are let's go right into Kelly Dodd I
love that you say Kelly Dodd look at
that I nice that I feel like you have to
say her first and last name how do you
do you really do you know what no wonder
wider you cheated on your wife
are you kidding me you know I Kelly
don't talk to me about cheating weren't
you she won your husband the party ended
with quite the screaming match it did it
says you regret that oh absolutely I saw
red and I didn't remember what I was
screaming at her I had to ask people
what did I say you know when you were
pushed to that level of anger so I'm not
proud of myself or for that at all and
then coming up we have an epic sushi
dinner right where Kelly hurls a certain
word your way she does freaking is what
you are I've never been called that word
before so there's a first time for
everything it's a very vicious attack
and everyone in the room was shaken up
after it that's all i have to say just I
don't know I don't know where it comes
from I don't have any explanations but
all of these things happen in less than
a week's period so i was pretty much
done I was pretty much done it was like
round three ready for round three where
do we go from that point where does this
relationship go but you know I I'm
always a person that forgives and people
will say oh what you did with Vicki yes
I did forgive Vicki I'm just not her
close friend anymore and I'm entitled to
make that decision for myself but you'll
see that there are my relationship with
Kelly you take some has some big ups
with some big down all right cheers to
that yes I'm glad to see you're still
standing here I am barely she just
kidding